sie sind die beiden kirchen die die welt
wie wir sie kennen verändert
hatten schon immer diese art von
respektlosigkeit als teil ihrer haltung
die sie so kreativ macht diese beiden
gründer halten sich wirklich für
edelmänner sie denken dass das was sie
tun gut für die welt ist
[Musik]
waren die typen die bilder nach bach
torna lisken aller tage
ich sagte minister gates was ist ihr
albtraum ich dachte er würde sagen apple
oder netscape oder oracle aber er sagte
ich mache mir sorgen dass jemand in
einer garage eine neue technologie
erfindet microsoft hatte über zwei jungs
in einer garage im jahr 98 nachgedacht
und über ein handgemaltes schild mit der
aufschrift google globales hauptquartier
ein ende in einer branche in der
innovation nur ein teil der
stellenbeschreibung ist sind larry page
und sergey brin zu virtuellen meistern
des universums der
informationsbeschaffung geworden was wir
nicht wissen wie google
und ich dachte die ganze zeit selbst zu
googlen würde was anderes bedeuten nicht
mehr silicon valley ist übersät mit
startups die ins stocken geraten sind
warum diese beiden informatik freaks
erfolgreich waren hat möglicherweise
viel mit dem fast parallelen leben zu
tun dass sie führten bevor sie eines der
größten und mächtigsten unternehmen der
welt gründungen brin und page lehnten es
respektvoll an unserem programm
teilzunehmen
sergey brin wurde 1973 in der
sowjetunion geboren seine eltern waren
mathematiker und juden was ihre
karrierechancen minderte
mag man sieht ist mitautor der gugl
story also ging's herr gates vater zu
einer konferenz in warschau traf eine
ganze reihe von kollegen aus dem westen
sah das leben außerhalb der sowjetunion
kam zurück setzte sich mit der familie
hin und sagte wir müssen gehen seine
eltern brachten eine zielstrebigkeit mit
die sie ihrem sohn bei brachten es lief
auf eine einfache nachricht hinaus bot
camberg öbb kommen nicht mit einem b
zurück com nicht mit dem zweiten platz
zurück sein erster immer gut
verinnerlicht dass es wurde ein kern
seiner persönlichkeit
larry page wurde wie brennen 1973
geboren seine familie lebte in michigan
und sein vater war der erste in seiner
familie der einen hochschulabschluss
hatte beide eltern waren auf ähnlichen
feldern prinz tätig
sie waren informatiker der zweiten
generation was für die damalige zeit
sehr ungewöhnlich war wenn die
informatik entwickelte sich als fach
eigentlich erst in den 60er jahren und
wir hatten beide eltern einen höheren
abschluss
sie sehen sich auf einer mission ob
diese mission entspringt wirklich ihren
biografien
[Musik]
in 2009 teilte paid dieser mission mit
der abschlussklasse der university of
michigan du weiß wie es ist mitten in
der nacht mit einem lebhaften traum
aufzuwachen und wenn du keinen bleistift
und keinen block neben dem bett hast ist
er am nächsten morgen verschwunden ich
hatte einen dieser träume als ich 23 war
ich wachte auf und dachte was wäre wenn
wir das ganze internet herunterladen und
nur die links behalten könnten ich
schnappte mir einen stifter und fing an
zu schreiben kurz danach erzählte ich
meine berater terry minarett dass es ein
paar wochen dauern würde um das web
herunterzuladen
doch er nickt wissend dass es viel
länger dauern würde aber glück genug es
mir nicht zu sagen
stanford professor und ingenieur berater
bei google terry mit larry denkt einfach
an möglichkeiten dinge zu tun die man
vielleicht nicht der wackelt sergej
waleri sehr ähnlich er war auch jemand
der wirklich über den tellerrand schauen
wollte um zu sagen wenn das unmöglich
klingt versuchen wir es war 1995 an der
stanford university als ich die
eigenwilligen überflieger zum ersten mal
trafen
eine ihrer stamford professoren sagte
immer der unterschied zwischen den
beiden vater sergej einfach in mein büro
stürmte ohne zu fragen larry wurde
klopfen und dann herein platzen
[Musik]
in den 90er jahren war die suche im
internet rudimentär auf gut glück
auf studien ergebnisse geliefert die
nutzlos waren und der prozess war sehr
langsam dann haben sie ihre anfrage
eingegeben und erst mal was anderes
gemacht und dann ging man zurück und sah
die ergebnisse und die meisten waren
völlig irrelevant page und brin drängten
auch etwas besseres
service großes interesse bestand darin
alle seiten im world wide web zu nehmen
und zu versuchen muster zu finden
sie begannen eine aufnahme von backlinks
zu machen wie sie sie nannten
page bemerkte dass sich hinter jeder
webseite hunderte oder sogar tausende
anderer seiten befanden die darauf
verlinkten tut
[Musik]
geht wo es war ein aha moment der das
sogenannte
informationszeitalter verändern würde
dann erkannten sie dass diese liste von
backlinks für das ranking verwendet
werden konnte wenn sie mehr backlinks
haben würde ihnen eine bessere seite
angezeigt wenn viele andere websites mit
einer website verlinkt waren bedeutete
das wahrscheinlich dass die benutzer sie
für gut hielten das genie erkannte dass
diese art von algorithmus ihnen die art
von ergebnissen liefern kamen die den
suchenden am wichtigsten sind page und
brin hatten ihre geheime formel jetzt
brauchte sie einen namen
die jungs sucht nach einem großartigen
namen der ihre grandiose vision
einfangen würde und stießen auf diese
riesigen nummer 1 mit hundert nullen
bekannt als google geoeye
doch sie war schon vergeben also sagten
sie weißt du was lasst uns eine nettere
schreibweise 53 jahren
am 15 september 1997 registrierten sie
google als website und page und brin
brachen ihre promotionen ab um sich auf
die suche nach finanzierungsmitteln für
junges unternehmen zu konzentrieren
es wurde nicht einfach investoren
zu dieser zeit gab es fünf suchmaschinen
und ich sagte dass vielleicht eine von
ihnen an der technologie interessiert
sein könnte die welt brauchte keine
sechste suchmaschine
[Musik]
google passte einfach nicht zu der
herkömmlichen auffassung davon was eine
website können nämlich die benutzer
davon abzuhalten zu einer anderen seite
zu wechseln google tat das undenkbar es
half benutzern das breitere internet zu
erkunden larry page und sergey brin
waren anderer meinung sie sagten wir
wollen kein portal wir wollen
suchergebnisse in sekundenbruchteilen
larian sergej saßen also eines
sonntagmorgens bei einem befreundeten
stanford-professor auf der veranda und
andy beck schein einer der gründer von
sun microsystems kam in seinem
sportwagen guckte sich eine zehnminütige
demo an sagte fantastisch das ist das
nächste große ding und schrieb einen
scheck über 100.000 dollar ausgestellt
auf google inc steven levy zehn reiter
des magazins wired so laufen die dinge
halt im silicon valley jetzt klingt
erstaunlich dass jemand einfach 100.000
dollar scheck ausstellt damit sie
starten können aber das ganze geschah
auch vor einem gewissen hintergrund sie
waren in stanford ihre professoren
hatten das schon mal gemacht das ist
eine ziemlich gute wette wir könnten
100.000 euro verlieren oder den großen
gewinn machen
und zu der zeit hatten wir ja noch gar
kein unternehmen wir konnten den check
nicht einließ
es gab keine juristischen dokumente
wissen sie nichts von diesem zeug
und obwohl sie das startgeld hatten
brauchten sie noch viel mehr bargeld
niemand kaufte sich aus unternehmen ein
also gingen sie zurück zur emscher sie
haben drei andere investoren gefunden
und zusammen haben wir genug geld
gesammelt um sie an den start zu bringen
genug geld war eine million dollar
darunter
250.000 dollar von jeff bezos von
amazon.com
page und brin gründeten google am 4
september 98 und zogen in eine dieser
geschichtsträchtigen garagen in menlo
park
sie erregten die aufmerksamkeit zweier
bekannter risikokapitalgeber aus dem
silicon valley michael moritz von
sequoia capital und condor von kleiner
perkins beide wollten einen exklusiven
deal
die beiden hatten damals echt nerven in
ihrem zarten alter von mitte 20 zu sagen
wir wollen kein geld von nur einem
risikokapitalgeber wir wollen
sicherstellen dass keiner von ihnen die
kontrolle hat also spalten wir uns auf
im juni 99 gab google seine erste
pressemitteilung heraus in der die
investition angekündigt wurde 25
millionen dollar rampage musste nun
erstklassige ingenieure einstellen leute
die ihren hohen ansprüchen genügen würde
ist ein ehemaliger googler es war eines
der intensivsten einstellungsverfahren
aller unternehmen weltweit
ich hatte nur wenigen tagen zwischen 12
und 15 interviews sie schufen eine
zentrale namens googleplex mit angeboten
für die mitarbeiter sie kostenloses
essen und kinderbetreuung das informelle
firmen motto don't be evil sei nicht
böse ich aber google verdiente immer
noch kein geld
larry kam rein und ich sagte wie willst
du damit geld verdienen die google
mitbegründer larry page und sergey brin
hatten eine neue suchmaschine entwickelt
mussten aber noch einen weg finden damit
auch geld zu machen
aber sie wollten das nicht mit werbung
zuerst dachten sie werbung so
schmuddelig kommerziell und irgendwie
unpassend sergey brin entwarf die
berühmt spärliche homepage
wahlen yahoo und aol weigerten sich brin
und page ihre seite mit werbung zu
überladen
wir nehmen keine werbung auf die
homepage wir wollen vertrauen aufbauen
und nicht das gefühl haben dass wir sie
mit werbung überhäufen doch keine
werbung bedeutete keine einnahmen page
und brin mussten werbung als einzige
option akzeptieren am anfang gab es
suchmaschinen bei denen die treffer wie
normale suchergebnisse aussahen aber
dinge waren für die die sponsoren die
suchmaschine bezahlkarten und sie sagten
das sei nicht gut für die nutzer ich
will nicht dass von dem andere wollen
dass ich es sehe sondern ich will das
was ich sehen will dann fanden sie einen
kompromiss
sie erfanden eine neue art werbung zu
platzieren
ausgelöst durch suchanfragen ins stadt
liegende anzeigen oder papas erschienen
diese kleinen anzeigen über und neben
den tradierten
heute ganz normal damals revolutionär
sie nannten es google adwords die
unternehmen konnten die kontrolle über
ihre werbegelder übernehmen entgegen sie
anzeigen schlüssel für bestimmte
werbetreibende nie um dieses system weil
sie nur zahlen wenn jemand tatsächlich
auf ihre anzeige klickt für viele
werbetreibende ist es die effizienteste
form des marketings die sie je hatten
für unternehmen war es der heilige gral
eine direkte verbindung zu ihren besten
kunden mit einer massiven neuen
einnahmequelle explodierte
bis september 2000 hatte die seite eine
milliarde url registriert und war in 15
sprachen verfügbar
trotzdem wussten nur wenige leute
außerhalb des silicon valley wer google
erschaffen hat
sergey brin sagte die wahrheit
und täuschte errichtet der echte severin
bitte aufstehen
aber medien mogul wussten genau wer sie
waren barry diller war einer der ersten
traditionellen medien manager der die
google jungs besuchte larissas damit zu
einem taschencomputer und schrieb seine
e mails unter sagte larry bitte ich rede
mit ihr können wir uns einfach
unterhalten und er sagt ich kann beides
und barry diller meint nein können sie
nicht wählen sie und er sagt
mit dem enormen wachstum kamen weitere
herausforderungen auf den suchenden
google zu die risikokapitalgeber des
unternehmens
drängten die mitbegründer einem schiff
sie waren dagegen aber sie wollten auch
nicht sagen hey wir könnten das doch
machen obwohl sie dachten sie könnten
das am ende durchliefen sie 12 13 14
interviews aber sie machten keinen von
denen also besuchten sie steve jobs weil
er ein held für sie war und
warum kann er nicht unser chef sein
sondern stellte page und brin eric
schmidt einem geschäftsmann mit
technischem hintergrund
sie haben gerade eric schmidt
eingestellt erst gekommen um google zu
leiten
steckt dahinter
könnt ihr das nicht selber machen
elterliche aufsicht um ehrlich zu sein
wissen sie eric ist der erwachsene hier
ich meine er ist mitte fünfzig nicht mit
der 30 er hat viel erfahrung er ist
diplomatischer als sie und das braucht
man im umgang mit der traditionell
medienwelt auf die sie immer häufiger
stoßen
[Musik]
ende 2001 wurde eric schmidt google
geschäftsführers übernahm und produkt
und bringen die technologie-sparte die
beiden gründer teilten sich immer noch
ein büro ihre geister sind miteinander
verschmolzen sie wissen was der andere
sagen will sind füreinander da es gibt
keine spannungen zwischen ihnen das ist
eine ihrer großen stärken
mit eric schmidt setzte google sein
spektakuläres wachstum fort während die
rivalen langsam verblasst nur
die suchmaschine war mit drei milliarden
webseiten verbinden und ging eine
partnerschaft mit aol ein die ihnen 34
millionen neuer kunden brachte
wenn man so ein unglaublich profitables
unternehmen haus wie kommt man ins
nächste level woher sollte das benötigte
kapital wachstum kommen
die lösung es war an der zeit für google
an die öffentlichkeit zu gehen
sie waren unkonventionell also
beschlossen sie einen börsengang
hinzulegen den wall street so noch nicht
gesehen hatte sie legten den preis über
eine auktion fest um den größtmöglichen
wert aus der aktie haus zu holen
der kurs schloss am 19 august 2004 bei
knapp über 100 dollar pro aktie womit
das unternehmen mehr als 23 milliarden
dollar wert war die beiden gründer
wurden milliardäre
stück wald expandierte das unternehmen
mit google maps google news und google
mit idealismus und kühnen ideen hatten
sie ihren ruf aufgebaut stolpert dann
aber über ihren kostenlosen e mail
service
google mail oder ein tolles aber
schlecht eingeführtes produkt
werbeanzeigen die sich direkt auf
persönliche e mails bezogen riefen bei
benutzern die alarmglocken schrillen als
diese leute diese anzeigen zum ersten
mal sahen waren sie schockiert sie
dachten wie können die so zielgerichtet
sein ich lese eine mail über den urlaub
eines freundes auf hawaii und bekomme
anzeigen über hawaii und schnüffelte
jemandem ein mails die bedenken lösten
eine noch viel grundlegendere diskussion
über datenschutz und vertrauen
wissen sie wie google die informationen
verwendet die es über sie sammelt all
die web suchen der letzten jahre die e
mails die ich geschrieben habe
möglicherweise informationen über meine
gesundheit über bücher die ich lese
darüber wohin ich gehe weil ich es in
google maps eingeben in gewisser weise
sind sie der big brother über den wir
all die jahre gesprochen haben
der big brother stellte seine
philosophie des nicht bösartig science
auf die probe
2006 einigte sich google mit china auf
den zugang zu seinen 400 millionen
internetnutzer
unter der bedingung dass sie verbotene
themen zensieren
verbringen sohn russischer einwanderer
eine beunruhigende entscheidung bei
einem freitags treffen von google sprach
sergej mit leidenschaft über das
aufwachsen in der sowjetunion und wie
seine eltern buchstäblich geflohen sind
und nach amerika zu kommen und was das
für ihn bedeutet sie haben und allen
mitarbeitern darüber gesprochen musste
schwer schlucken aber bei google haben
alle gesagt das ist der größte
verbraucher markt der welt wir müssen da
rein
google stimmte chinas forderungen zu
ich weiß es gab eine menge kontroversen
darüber und wir mussten ziemlich viel
zensieren aber es wurde immer weniger
und unsere lokalen konkurrenten dort
haben auch immer weniger zensiert also
hat unsere teilnahme auch etwas bewegt
aber
trotzdem ging es dann irgendwie bergab
google entdeckte einen cyberangriff auf
seine systeme
das beunruhigende für mich ist dass wir
entdeckt haben welche motivation
dahinter steckt nämlich an gmail konten
zu kommen vor allem von chinesischen
menschenrechtsaktivisten
google zog den stecker und leitete die
nutzer auf eine ungefilterte seite in
hongkong um die nicht der zensur
unterlag
begann als plattform für heimvideos und
entwickelte sich bald zu einer der
weltweit führenden suchmaschinen im juli
2006 luden benutzer täglich
65.000 videos hoch und google wollte da
rein
sie kauften youtube für 1,65 milliarden
dollar in google aktien die youtube
gründer chad hurley und steve chen
heute haben wir spannende neuigkeiten
für euch wir wurden von google ja danke
2006 erkannte google chef eric schmidt
unternehmen auch in die welt der
mobiltelefone einsteigen muss
tatsächlich hatten sie ein jahr zuvor
stillschweigend ein start-up gekauft
android ein kleines unternehmen für
handy-software
es gibt so viel mehr handys als computer
die leute surfen immer mehr übers handy
im internet am ende sollte es sich
ausgleichen aber das wird auch wieder
viele jahre dauern es hat nicht jahre
gedauert der phänomenale erfolg von
apple mit dem iphone brachte die
unternehmen 2007 auf kollisionskurs
monate später
der einstieg ins telefongeschäft brachte
ihr langjähriges idol steve jobs gegen
sie aus er beschuldigte sie das iphone
töten zu wollen
auf einer google entwicklerkonferenz im
mai 2010 setzte sich der vize präsident
der technikabteilung mit apple
auseinander
google musste handeln
sonst würde es in zukunft nur einen mann
ein unternehmen ein gerät bei einem
betreiber geben
so einer zukunft wollten
und google kämpft noch mit einem anderen
giganten an der technologie welt sie
stoßen auf so viele arten mit microsoft
zusammen sie haben einen browser chrome
microsoft hat
auch unternehmen die mit
online-versionen von text und tabellen
software handelten dinge die direkt auf
microsofts halsschlagader zielten
microsoft feuerte mit seiner eigenen
suchmaschine bing zurück in die im
frühjahr 2009 an den start gehen darf
ich fragen was du von beust magst du es
ich denke sind sie ein benutzer
nein ich benutze alle suchmaschinen ich
denke dass zwingen uns daran erinnert
dass die internetsuche einen sehr
umkämpfter markt ist
[ __ ] tumpel ironischerweise schutz weil
sich damit der vorwurf ein monopol zu
sein erledigt
bill gates sagte dieser konkurrent ist
uns von allen am nächsten die sind
genauso hungrig und rücksichtslos er hat
dieses wort nicht benutzt aber ich tu's
sie laufen gefahr sich viele feinde zum
beiden gründer haben sich immer für
edelmänner gehalten sie dachten das was
sie tun ist gut für die welt
sie haben es genossen sich wie die
underdogs zu führen microsoft als den
bösen
aber jetzt merken sie dass manche leute
sie für die bösen halten
ihr eigener slow in don't be evil wo das
plötzlich gegen sie verwendet
[Musik]
großen bild ziel informationen zu
organisieren schlug eine neue richtung
ein mit einem ambitionierten feature
namens
mit dem ziel jedes viertel der welt zu
fotografieren
von normalen straßen bildern/s
hin zu außergewöhnlichen ansichten der
antarktis
allerdings wurden dafür auch nutzer
informationen aus ungesicherten
wlan-netzen verwertet eine verletzung
der privatsphäre
google gab den fehler zu und musste
daher nicht
das unternehmen kämpfte darum wo
vielfältiger zu werden und sah sich
einem aggressiven neuen herausforderer
gegenüber mark zuckerberg eine milliarde
facebook-nutzer und hosten wertvolle
informationen die für die suchmaschine
von google
informationen die alle werbetreibenden
haben
bisher hatte google mit sozialen
netzwerken keinen erfolg
aber den gründern ist bewusst dass ihr
unternehmen mit den sich ändernden
nutzergewohnheiten mithalten
[Musik]
im januar 2011 gab eric schmidt
überraschend bekannt dass google seine
verwaltungssprecher vereinfacht und dass
larry page bereit sei ihn als
mitbegründer sergey brin konzentrierte
sich auf neue produkte schmecken
twitterte keine tägliche aufsicht durch
erwachsene männer
innerhalb von 14 jahren wuchs google von
start up zum technologieriesen und
erzielte 2012 einen umsatz von 50
milliarden dollar
larry page und sergey brin waren
inzwischen verheiratet
page nahm im dezember 2007 die
promovierte stanford bio informatikerin
lose in das auf der insel von richard
branson frau grenzen war auch sein
trauzeuge drin heiratete auf den bahamas
die biotechnologie spezialistin android
ski und sein partner larry page stand
ihm zur seite beide haben zwei kinder
google.org der gemeinnützige zeigt das
unternehmen hat über 100 millionen
dollar an verschiedene organisationen
gespendet von sauberer energie bis hin
zu globaler gesundheit larry page und
sergey brin haben die art wie wir
informationen erhalten verändert
es war eine großartige erfahrung für
mich sie in diesen zwölf jahren die ich
sie kenne wachsen zu sehen ich bin sehr
stolz auf das was sie erreicht haben
harry und sally hatten schon immer diese
art von respektlosigkeit als teil ihrer
haltung die sie so kreativ gemacht hat
ich denke google zieht leute an die sich
kümmern um die nutzer ihre mitmenschen
um den planeten die einfach nicht herum
sitzen wollen sie haben ein unternehmen
aufgebaut das die welt absolut verändert
hat
[Musik]